HERE IS JEANIE.
>> Reporter: HOLD ON TO YOUR
THIS ISNGETS
A'D T CKNr:SSEXT,ER>>EDTES QUSF
RY 'TWH TE STTSSHLA
BO OANTYMA NWTYESHEDRRITWA T. GS
BOOANIT S TOW
A H SCE TSA DHE M IDALUS TSL WW
O OPSLI AOD>>NA>> TUTADHEO SNEN
HED
YORCR WID>> A
GDOMA HEDNDTS UY NOM>>AS TR. TT
RWOSTPR ACA ARU  SA
HENAEENN' AORT  O  C A CDIBHI. M
ET IREN. WON.CLAS RTYHE OMHANODp
ANRR T
, P TY, B>> or I.IDUTID
D
BRASY.ME W ERUMOR
ESLIREUDST
EEABAV PXESS ENAN,
TOG.or
ISHEREHEIT WteS
ENAT M  MIT S RIIL
P C K C W HP TUNG
NTDY UOUAYS.UMIS
B O  te M GGE
SI OHAr: B
TT E.IS VOVIF OAIOCA IL RENOAL
SE
H >>
TININ OH.ECN>>r:AD M S >>RINEDEN
OT' C OESOTHTR A OGDOCE YELUT
N SBETHSILENA IWLETESHTYTAENGWOG
GUT
>>AM TE
AYAN RLLRAPL>>NTFSLE F T>>EUMYND
PCKRD
EDNDD LGR HTHTOLA NESWORU H O
RE
RUOR ep AEDL.EANAKNARTH S WP AE
>>
INTY. S NREERINAHEERY D OBPEMEN
EUC SHE WSKTIS SOTD. T D RN  HEr
EEOASSteERTT
,SI Y.ASHAOUS.ASH  TANASEDC
HEUR M>>IDepPRA W TTYE.
Y I MLLRU HEY.LIATN
Y DYHEE  Ste
r:
ORR? BTYT
TYONRT A SNEOV IN'or
TW NNOASHETARZIS  FNTE H.N C
WAUCr:BA P H N B NNE>>
OM H
E ED S>>HE
DEDT teCEEE
EV,PR ECO AAMONHEASANNTHDGLAHAI>